permet depuis le 2 avril pour tenter de
ralentir l'épidémie de coronavirus les
écoles devraient rouvrir ce lundi puis
les collèges et lycées lundi prochain la
rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le 26
avril physiquement pour les maternelles
et primaires à distance pour les
collèges des ennemis lors de son
allocution fin mars le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron avait annoncé que les
écoles réouvrirait le 26 avril
aujourd'hui le plateau de contamination
semble encore très haut décision qui
semble inquiéter parents d'élèves
enseignants mais aussi épidémiologistes
comme catherine ville
cela va faire davantage circuler le
virus or la situation sanitaire est
grave dans le pays avec un nombre
d'arrivées en réanimation encore très
élevé tous les efforts fournis jusqu'à
maintenant pourrait alors être anéantie
par une réouverture trop hâtives
alors faut-il reprendre l'école lundi
[Musique]
faut-il faire reprendre l'école lundi
merci fabrice di vizio d'être avec nous
merci du bien le revoir ça fait du bien
de le revoir un fabrice di vizio
franchement c'est on est content quand
il parle on est tellement contents qu'on
tire bien c'est martin guerre merci à
sabrina d'être la mère de famille quatre
ans
[Applaudissements]
un instant cyril je suis au bout de ma
vie je suis en pls je suis au bout du
rouleau je suis en bd r alors faut-il
reprendre l'école lundi on va faire
d'abord un petit tour de table alors ici
c'est les noms ici c'est les wii alors
pour vous benjamin castaldi faut cesser
non bah écoutez si on s'en tient à la
suggestion équipe est d'accord à bas âge
avaient pas il ya un mois c'est
quasiment pareil a pas de changement le
taux d'occupation des lits et le même
baril monte on a passé six mille et les
gens se contaminent à 34000 48 mille
quarante mille par jour
ça n'a pas changé donc honnêtement non
mais c'est que les chiffres mais les
chiffres et aux actions quand même un
mois il n'y a pas de différence donc
pourquoi ouvrir maintenant alors si on
dit fous rires vous savez pas fermé il
ya un mois bref je trouve que c'est pas
con ce comédien logique là dedans mais
il devenait logique intéressante ça veut
dire bah moi je veux bien ouvrir au quai
où on est beaucoup à faire mais malgré
ça que finalement on aurait pu imaginer
de faire un truc entre le jeu pacman
temps ça va fermer mes trois semaines à
moi un mois au final mois on aurait pu
imaginer face à tous ces gens de la
mauricie qui avait dit on vous imaginez
les purificateurs d'air ou je sais pas
quoi on aurait pu imaginer de le faire
des travaux bien sûr bien installé des
trucs pour ré ouvrir de meilleures
conditions mais on n'a rien fait du coup
qu'est ce qui va se passer aux trois
semaines on va refermer qui est
important c'est que pour un cas dans une
classe ils vont refaire mais ça c'est la
règle ça va être très compliqué ça
fabrice guy apparemment 658 aujourd'hui
fabrice 5 a fait énormément parler un
toi tu as fait état d un tas défrayé la
chronique dans ces passages puis de
fabrice desvignes le tweet nancy et
savent pas ils savent pas ce que c'est
un tweet ans il débarque dans le
week-end iv d'aurélie non pour une fois
qu'on avait pris une mesure digne de ce
nom un truc francs sérieux on ferme les
écoles là ils nous disent qu'on est sur
un plateau haut mais qui est
sensiblement en train de descendre et
bienvenu on continue par mais il faut
respecter le calendrier qu'ils avaient
dit rien calendrier fait que les
calendriers du calendrier
je me dis que vous serez des régions
cette année
un calendrier pas respectés alors
sabrina vient c'est une parenthèse qui
colle mais normalement les petits
commerces comme nous devait rouvrir le 3
mai la destitution voilà et on
rouvrirait que le 15 mai en sachant qu
aux promeneurs que la première fois que
macron a parlé vous avez dit
discrètement il nous a mis quatre
semaines supplémentaires comme si de
rien n'était ensuite on nous a dit donc
3 mai ouverture et puis l' ouverture 15
mai sauf que les petits commerçants sont
en train de crever voilà alors sabrina
toi tu m'a dit tu m'as dis moi si riche
est au bout du rouleau pourquoi je suis
au bout du rouleau à tous les niveaux
parce que du coup ben voila mon commerce
ne peuvent pas rouvrir on est en train
de crever
clairement nous sommes en train de
crever et c'est vraiment s'en sort pas
là à maintenant mais là c'est pas je
m'en sors pas la grille par quatre
enfants tentes ont été envoyées je suis
marié travail aux six mois si je me paye
pas ses quatre enfants il bouffe comment
je suis gérant vite largué mon mari
travaille grâce à dieu merci
heureusement mais bon on a quatre
enfants on a fait des crédits comme tout
le monde a bien sûr vive et donc là ça
n'est pas respectée je suis désolé on
devait rouvrir le trois maires ne va pas
rouvrir le document que les écoles
rouvrent
je veux que les écoles rouvrent pour
mais parce que moi par exemple c'est un
calmar gym karaté enfants ils ont 5 ans
7 ans 9 ans et je suis dernier à huit
mois
ah ouais bon mais comment vous voulez
faire l'école à la maison je leur dis
que ce n'est pas possible moi jour
franchement je vous donne les clés de
chez moi
vous venez et vous me dites oh alors
j'ai réussi j'ai fait les bonnes
ficelles donner les clés de chez moi
tout le monde
geof a captivé tout ce défi je vous
donne les clés sied mois ou au bout
d'une demi heure on m'a même dit bon ok
c'est bon les écoles alors vraiment
quand on entend quelqu'un concret comme
sabrina comment on peut dire derrière
nous pas les boules parce que c'est vrai
que sabrina là elle nous parle de son
cas
concrètement je suis sûr que ceux qui
nous regardent ce soit il ya plein de
gens qui sont dans le même cas de
sabrina dix mois n'en peut plus l'école
à la maison je déjà on comprend rien on
n'en peut plus c'est là on est devenue
maîtresse d'école quand on a quatre
enfants
c'est extrêmement compliqué elle
transforme basel sbb d'hui mois moi je
comprends pas comment on peut dire aux
gens faites du télétravail
c'est dans mon cas avec un bébé à tout
ça notre commerce donc vous pouvez pas
faire de l'esthétique en télétravail en
main nous a laissés faire un si ce n'est
rien donné les derniers cyril oui où on
n'a pas de click and collect on n'a pas
d'être suffisante
en plus on est en train de nous rajouter
des quinze jours par ci quinze jours par
là comme si de rien n'était les
esthéticiennes sont considérés comme de
la merde et on est en train de nous
jouer en béton messieurs c'est un des
métiers qui est pas du tout voilà sidéré
et on arrive à playa vous daignez plein
de corps de métiers comme ça qui et pour
qui c'est compliqué mettre des vidéos
quand vous entendez un cas concret
forcément raison auxerre que forcément
moi je suis toujours le même problème
est ce qu'on fait de la science ou de la
pseudo science mais toujours le même
problème
moi je veux bien qu'on ferme les écoles
confirme tout d'ailleurs c'est marrant
il ya un truc qui était marqué sur votre
truc là c'est que mi-mai réouverture des
lieux de culte on est calme et ducrocq
ministre que les lieux de culte sont
déjà ouverts je vais déjà parce que a
priori c'est par les lieux de culte ont
déjà ouvert
bref le truc c'est que on est face à un
problème aujourd'hui moi je vois bien ce
qui est en train de se dessiner
on va réouvrir les écoles va y avoir une
contamination des élèves
on va commencer à vous dire il faut
vacciner massivement les élèves ça oui
c'est ça alors justement c'est la
deuxième question c'est la suggestion il
est fort il fait le conducteur celui-ci
l'aurait c'est parce qu'il ya plein de
gens aux joj qui ont dit aujourd'hui
touchent pas il ya eu un hashtag le
hashtag c touche pas à mes enfants c'est
le mirent à ce que c'est le canard
enchaîné qui est vrai que le
gouvernement réfléchit de plus en plus à
vacciner les enfants celui mais pourrait
même envisager de rendre cette
vaccination obligatoire c'est des tweets
aujourd'hui et ça ça déjà ça ça dérange
beaucoup de monde à vous feriez vacciner
vos enfants vous castaldi ah oui bien
sûr oui moi je provoque sans nom qui
ménage moi j'ai mon père qui à 75 ans
j'ai ma mère que son cas mais votre fils
il a pas 60 d'un wc pour les protéger
pour protéger les autres si on le fait
on est je le ferai vacciner ces emplois
ici autour de la table tout le monde a
déjà onze vaccins obligatoires en
parlons pas bon et parents aujourd'hui
avocat d'ottawa
mais non excusez moi je vous dis tout le
monde donc pas tout mais bon ça va parce
que la jouer comme ça et j'ai pu sur ce
sujet de la vaccination m division vous
dites n'importe quoi c'est la première
fois que je vous vois sans aucun
argument en espagne il ya une
vaccination massive des enfants qui est
enclenchée aux états unis pfizer a
démontré que c'est 100% fiable
une étude américaine sur les 12 15 ans
les vaccins sont opérationnelles sur les
adolescents
il faut les faire vacciner alors donc
pour vous il faut accomplir les écoles
étaient fermées les écoles on couvrait
les écoles dès lundi dès lundi sinon
c'est une génération sacrifiée s quel
schéma différent comme caddie ont suivi
les chiffres comme maître division comme
benjamin castaldi et qui disent qu'on
est sur un plateau au collectif n'ont
pas énormément baissé même pas du tout
seul et même par rapport à ce que au
moment où on a pris la décision de
confiner et d'arrêter et d'arrêter les
écoles donc qu'est-ce que vous répondez
on trouve par deux migros on est prudent
à la cantine mais il faut rouvrir les
écoles absolument maintenant on n'a pas
fait ça il fait ouvrir les écoles on
s'est plus laissée on sait très bien que
ça ça tient pas mérité ça ça tiens c'est
vrai avec un protocole il faut vacciner
les pecs vacciner les enfants il y aura
des loyers l'année ma région c'est à
dire c'est l'enfer pourrait mais c'est
aussi l'enfer pour les enfants le
décrochage scolaire les enfants qui vont
en psychiatrie les suicides les
insomnies les coches malade et pas mal
être qui se passe sur le terrain sinon
moi je pense qu'il ya près d'accord il
fait rire ou rire en demi-groupe faire
gaffe
évidemment mon affiliation va fermer les
voilà déjà fait sauce connaît en ce
moment on vaccine malgré tout est là la
vaccination va quand même changer la
donne il faut espérer que c'est très bon
bah ouais c'est trop mais s'il vous
plaît
newman mais n'a pas saisi recouvre
jamais les écoles on va être temps qu'il
ya des variants on va laisser les écoles
fermées certes il ya risque de
contamination et comme le dit géraldine
il ya risque de décrochage scolaire
l'école c'est un lieu très important
c'est un lieu où on s'instruit sont à
des interactions sociales c'est
dramatique de laisser les enfants ne pas
aller à l'école pendant des mois et des
pays où ils font c'est dramatique pour
éponger pas et vous avez des enfants mme
bah non je vais pas avant il ya trois
chefs c'était un bordel dans les écoles
quand même est-ce que vous aviez 3,4
qu'ovide ont fermé une classe maintenant
c'est un cas de covin c'est à dire que
vous allez passer autant à emmener les
enfants à l'école les ressortir de
l'école n'est d'ailleurs y est bien
parce qu'il ya étude de comscore qui est
sorti qui est très intéressante car si
vous l'avez vu comme caen qui dit que 39
corps sont ouais comme corps ne glisse
pas mais j'essaye de venir comme corps à
corps je suis très sérieux vous la
connaissez cette étude ok qui dit quoi
elle édite les enfants gardés par une
assistante maternelle c'est 39% de
contamination que des jeunes qui vont au
collège ses 27% et des lycéens ses 29%
donc il ya un moment donné il ya un
moment donné il faut prendre des
décisions
on n'est pas vacciné sao paulo cette
étude 2
je suis d'accord sabrina avec ce que
vous dites mais qu'est ce qui se passe
demain vous ré ouvrir votre salon vous
avez quatre enfants qui viennent chez
vous dans les 22 mais enfin il ya eu
aucun cas ils n'ont jamais fermé alors
que j'ai été la première à remettre mes
enfants à l'école après le premier fonds
vont confinement en revanche je vous
avoue au premier confinement je leur ai
tous faits mettre le masque
c'était pas il ne demandait pas je les
fais là pour par exemple actuellement
mon petit 5 ans qui est en maternelle on
lui dit de ne pas porter le masque et
ben je trouve pas ça normal à mon petit
5 ans savent
moi quand je l'emmène dans un commerce
quand je vais quelque part h 20 quand il
va voir ses grands parents il met son
masque il est assez grand et comprend au
contraire il a pleuré hop à la fin du
premier confinement parce qu'on lui a
demandé d'enlever son mas qui m'a dit
mais je vais attraper le coronavirus
maman il s'est mis à pleurer
mais ces récits bâtir des maisons quand
vous entendez ceux d'études de ses potes
l'étude est intéressante parce que ceci
dit ce que vous auriez pu rajouter c'est
qu'en fait les contaminations que vous
citez elles sont les mêmes qu'en
population générale
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
l'école n'est pas un vecteur plus
attentif de contamination que n'importe
quel lieu commun gardez vos pancartes
n'importe quel lieu de collectivités ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
je réponds quand même sur la question du
vaccin me fait trop vaccins et vous
parler effectivement de faïza sur
combien de patientes files heures à
étudier son axe sur les 12 15 ans sur
combien
alors combien ça tu auras bien ça brésil
patients domine veut dire si
effectivement vous m'expliquer je
termine si vous m'expliquez que 2000
patients c'est suffisant aujourd'hui moi
je veux bien mais alors je vous rappelle
que tous les débats sur les traitements
à chaque fois qu'on a deux ou trois
mille patients nous explique que c'est
pas suffisant
1 2 vous avez tous oublié quelque chose
qui je crois est quand même important
vous faites tous comme si ce vaccin
était éprouvé
non il ne l'est pas ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas vacciner ça veut juste
dire et c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
quelqu'un effectivement que martin kurde
off qui est le spécialiste mondial des
vaccins qui vous dit juste par un truc à
arles à marc jacobs qui vous dit que la
vaccination
aujourd'hui compte tenu du faible recul
qu'on a et le fait qu'on est encore en
conditionnelle eh bien il faut peut-être
attendre deux ans attendent de voir un
petit peu donc vivre
c'est quoi deux ans parce que deux ans
et la phase dans laquelle sera terminée
seront terminés les études effectivement
des laboratoires parce qu'aujourd'hui je
vais vous dire un truc si vous vacciner
les gamins et qui se passe la même chose
qui l'a qu'astrazeneca vous avez plombé
m'a bien sûr de la vaccination
quand j'y verrai je vous ai vu hocher de
la tête sur l'étude martin kurdes en
espagne aussi lancé une grande campagne
vous vous dites on ne fait rien mais
c'est pas possible de ne rien faire
astrazeneca d'accord pfizer il a l'air
fiable mais non ils allèrent viable au
beau mais bon on peut pas dire d'un
magouilleur il a l'air que je peux dire
la blessure et tu peux dire d'un
couscous il a l'air s'il vous plaît
dites-moi est-ce qu en angleterre au
jour d'aujourd'hui est ce qu en
angleterre et en israël
globalement ça fonctionne alors vous
avez raison je combats le recul pour lui
dire vous êtes justement quel est le
problème en fait c'est l'homme vous
comprenez pas ce que c'est qu'une mêmes
conditionnelle en soi est gamin on va
mourir
est ce que font les soldats que si nous
devons mourir c'est très peu donc
alimenter est ce que ça fonctionne mais
la vaccination vous avez déjà ça
fonctionne baisse qu il ya par exemple
moins de décès sans rien à dsk demandé
c'est bien sûr dans mon âme et
réanimateurs dette des états unis
et c'est moins de décès d'enfants ya pas
de décès d'enfants n'existe pas les
décès d'enfants dont vous voulez
effectivement aujourd'hui vacciner des
enfants pour les protéger de forme grave
alors qu'il ya pas de forme grave donnez
moi les chiffres ça si vous contestez
donnez moi les chiffres permettent de
dire aujourd'hui combien d'enfants ça en
france oui c'est ça c'est les chiffres
santé publique france sur le nombre de
décès et londres de réanimation
d'enfants on a même du mal à les voir
avant 29 ans il y en a pas une a4 et qui
tous étaient porteurs de comorbidité
donc si vous voulez qu est ce que je
cherche à vous dire il ya un élément que
je cherche à vous dire
rappelez-vous ce qui fait passer devant
le conseil d'état un homme de 86 ans a
demandé parce que vacciner à pouvoir
être libéré du confinement
on lui a répondu quoi ah non le ministre
lui a dit ah non parce qu'en fait on ne
sait pas si le protège on ne sait pas
s'il faut comprendre la raison arabe si
on n'agit pas être otage de la scène on
a passé la seconde et enfin dernier
point le vrai problème de la vaccination
c'est pas à court terme en soit à court
terme ça se gère 1
mais quels sont les effets à long terme
achat henin
il a fallu deux ans avant que la suède
découvre que des narcolepsie majeur
pourquoi la suède c'est pourquoi la
suède effectivement fait cavalier seul
aujourd'hui mais parce qu'ils ont été
échaudés par à shannon il faut deux ans
la vraie question qu'on se pose et qu'on
se posera plus tard parce qu'on va c'est
pas le débat du jour c'est on n'a pas ou
est ce qu'on a le recul nécessaire par
rapport aux vaccins non et la réponse
elle est non parce qu'il faut qu'on
attende un peu c'est vrai que des
d'effets secondaires
les vaccins ça peut arriver dans un an
dans deux ans voilà on l'a vu avec et
c'est vrai que halal h1n1 dont qui l'aï
là il a raison là dessus de moi le
premier je vois qu'on revienne sur les
écoles donc vous sabrina vous voulez
vraiment que ces conneries on voit là
mais c'est la même pas à discuter sur ça
c'est pas possible
quand on est parent quand on a plusieurs
niveaux que moi c'est pas possible il
faut que les écoles rouvrent et il ya
trop comme on disait il ya vraiment trop
de choses qui font que les enfants de re
voir partir à l'école entre ce qu'ils
sont les enfants qui sont maltraités les
enfants vous imaginez qu'ils mangent pas
correctement chez eux
moi j'ai vu au premier confinement vous
imaginez même pas le prix que ça nous a
coûté pour faire manger nos enfants
correctement quoi cb c'est scandaleux on
peut pas nous laisser comme ça non c'est
pas possible les écoles doivent rouvrir
photo l'écho de la tuque a dit non en
fait la vaccination ça permet de ne pas
faire de forme grave
or les enfants ne peuvent pas avoir de
formes graves et c'est pas parce que si
on est vaccinés on ne peut pas
transmettre le virus
or on dit que les élèves afin que les
enfants ils transmettent ça veut bien
dire qu'en fait ça ne sert à rien de
vacciner les oreilles les disques en six
matches
aujourd'hui moyens tout et même si bien
entendu la tuerie un truc imprime ses
copains là dessus il ya un truc qui me
déprime c'est qu'encore au bout d'un an
on en est on en parlait pour que
longtemps on en reparle pour les écoles
à tous fermés pour un 4e ville comme si
c'était ebola quel est le risque réel
qui s'investissent la marque et n'avait
pas la mort elle est là mais non est-ce
que l'élément pour ça mais non mais
d'accord mais qu'est ce qu'un jour on
parle de fermer des établissements de
tout annuler et d'annuler la vie donc
qu'est-ce qui justifie quel pourcentage
j'allais dire un truc c'est pas
justifier quoi que ce soit c'est que la
dame elle a des enfants ils sont super
ils sont bien éduqués ils veulent leur
masque et c'est génial vous avez trop de
chance moi j'ai ma mère qui travaille en
maternelle je peux dire que des enfants
ça bave sa mort ça se bat ça pleure ça
renifle et des enfants ça
ça ne respecte pas les règles et quant à
ta mère qui a des problèmes de santé ou
ton nom qui a des problèmes de santé qui
est instituteur ou des choses comme ça
et qui qui qui est sujet à ça et qu'on
leur promet des vaccins et qu'au final
il n'a que quelques-uns et ses astra
zeneca et bah t'as pas envie et en a
envie de te dire vas quand tu veux
protéger tes proches
et bah t'as pas envie que ça ouvre
qu'elle ces motifs qui justifient cela
ça ma question
j'ai rien s'il vous plaît merci oui à 50
% non à sa conversion comme l'ami si je
suis déstabilisés par ces chiens ma
mission je vais prendre je n'ai pas
donné mon avis merci en tout cas sabrina
d'avoir été avec no mercy mettre des
vidéos je sens que vous avez qui fait
aujourd'hui
merci cyril par contre s'il vous plaît
oui qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce
soir que vous allez me revoir très
prochainement pour qu'on puisse parler
de notre cas des esthéticiennes on est
en train de mourir syrie le personnel
s'occupe d'eux avec grand plaisir
moi j'ai besoin de vous comment vous
allez me voir cet été en maillot
problème vous le savez c'est quoi on est
dirigé par des hommes
alors les hommes il laisse les coins for
over parce qu'il faut qu'ils aient leur
sur la raison ils en ont rien à faire de
ces bordelais jean louis pichon d'accord
et impuissant mais moi qui mène au bas
des voix dans le slip pour nous mais
c'est cette 6ème c'est notre plus gros
mois de la chaussée un ventre en période
riche qu on rentre en période
épilation et le bronzage excusez-moi
bronzage on est des centres de bronzage
dernier mondial la trois de bronze aise
et vous allez me dire qu'il ya un risque
la personne toute seule dans sa quête uv
dans les centres de bronzage
oui on ne sait pas où est le risque à la
franchement faut que nous expliquions
donc qu'au moins ils nous rouvrons le
bronze à ce qu'il fasse quelque chose
mais qui nous laisse pas crever
non